spider-man far from home is an intense
game changing movie that clocks in at
over two hours long but there are still
some amazing deleted scenes cut from the
final film as well as a completely
different alternate ending yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers I'm John and in this video
I'm revealing
16 deleted scenes cancelled characters
and the ending to the movie you never
got to see I've got a new Marvel
giveaway on this video so subscribe hit
the bell and let me know what you
thought of far from home for a chance to
win spoilers ahead of course so take
care if you haven't seen it yet the
movies writers Chris McKenna and Eric
summers have revealed there are deleted
scenes with happy hogan where he's
stumbling through different descriptions
and trying to come up with a term of his
own for peter spider-sense in the final
film however it's Aunt May who gets to
name Peters special power in the MCU I
thought that you could sense that with
your and Peter tingle the reason the
writers chose Spidey's aren't to coin
that particular phrase was to dial up
the embarrassment factor for Peter
do not start calling it my Peter tingle
the worst think of Peters that may is
also told happy and it looks like the
term is gonna stick you given Peter
tingle back online before Peter left for
his school trip to Europe originally he
had a long to-do list of things that
ended up being cut from the movie Kitsch
passport you Department who to pick up a
passport please
yeah many to his face take down the man
Freddy Marvin and there's an awesome
extended action scene of Peter taking
down the man Freddy crime syndicate
you go Mia next time right now well no I
don't have time I'm too busy doing your
jobs I'm kidding I'm kidding look keep
up the good work
because I am going on vacation I love
that guy this deleted scene is a nice
bit of street-level action and feels
similar to how Spidey took down the ATM
criminals in spider-man homecoming the
Manfredi crime family a prominent
spider-man villains in the comics and
hardcore MCU fans may also recall that
they appeared in the second season of
agent Carter where Joseph Manfredi was
the leader of a bigger crime syndicate
called the Maggio also on the to-do list
that was cut from the movie was Peter
getting the dual headphone adapter he
wanted for watching movies together with
MJ as well as a European travel plug and
toothpaste for this he visited Del Mar
store which previously featured in
homecoming putting a trip mmm-hmm going
to Europe school trip remembrance
Spidey's first solo film that mr. Del
Mar thought spider-man was fighting The
Avengers when he saw him taking on some
masked criminals in fact Del Mar's
bodega was destroyed when the criminals
Tex burn out of control during that
fight after the deli caught fire Spidey
jumped in to rescue mr. Del Mar and his
cat MuRF and you can see that moment
referenced in the deleted scene in the
newspaper cuttings that are up on the
wall also chopped from the new movie was
Peter going to collect his passport for
his trip abroad Peter Parker here to
pick up a passport please
that dialogue sounds like the writers
were going for something along the lines
of the well-known tongue twister Peter
Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers
now you might have noticed that this
passport doesn't have any years on it
either for Peters year of birth or for
the issue or expiration dates the years
may have simply been removed to avoid
potentially giving away any spoilers for
end games however Marvel did mess up the
timeline in spider-man homecoming with
an eighth year time jump which they had
to wreck on later when they released an
official timeline for the MCU so perhaps
leaving out the dates as a little nod to
that by the way there's a nice Easter
Egg in the day and month for Peter's
birthday on the passport the 10th of
August 1962 was the date that spider-man
debuted in Marvel Comics another deleted
scene from Peters trip preparations saw
him selling all of his toys to raise
enough money for the Black Dahlia
necklace that he buys for MJ
Venice the scene had Peter getting a
little emotional because among the
various toys he was selling was some
vintage Star Wars action figures that
were supposed to have originally
belonged to Uncle Ben the action figures
appeared on the shelf in Peters room in
homecoming and there's one character
Lobot which is a favorite of Marvel
Studios chief Kevin Feige that Peter
would have ended up keeping Lobot is
Lando Calrissian administrator in Cloud
City and although he doesn't get any
speaking lines in Empire Strikes Back he
does were a distinctive looking
cybernetic headpiece which enables him
to communicate with the city's central
computer the irony of this deleted scene
is that although as we've known since
civil war Peter Parker is a Star Wars
fan hey guys actor Tom Holland has
admitted that he's not really into Star
Wars himself and hasn't even seen the
Empire Strikes Back
so he doesn't really know who Lobot is
by the way Peter scrambling to get some
money together to impress MJ with a gift
in the MCU reminds me of how Tobey
Maguire's Peter Parker took part in a
wrestling match with the idea of buying
a car to impress Mary Jane in Sam
Raimi's first spider-man film far from
homes director John Watson Tom Holland
have both said all these deleted scenes
in New York were cut because the
intention was to get Peter and the other
students to Europe as quickly as
possible
these discarded scenes will be appearing
as part of a Marvel one-shot a bonus
short film which will be on the movies
blu-ray release there's a moment in far
from home where Nick Fury tranquilisers
Ned with a dart in a scene that calls
back to Captain America the Winter
Soldier Peter's been dodging Fury's
phone calls so Fury's arrived in person
to ask the Spidey's help and as they
leave the hotel room there's an amusing
clip that ended up getting Curt is he
gonna be okay like that might want to
turn him over so he doesn't swallow his
tongue one location that Peter almost
visited with his classmates on the
European tour is new Asgard which is
where the surviving Asgardian settled
after the events of Ragnarok and worth
for and Co were hanging out playing
video games and Avengers end game it
could have been fun to see Peter Parker
cross paths with Valkyrie the new queen
of Asgard and also check in with meek
and Korg for an update on noob master 69
the movies mid credit
scene was pretty amazing with the
surprise return of JK Simmons j jonah
Jameson has a conspiracy theorist
commentator for The Daily Bugle website
offering up one of his typically
prejudiced rants where he twists the
truth about spider-man saying he's the
real villain fans have been going crazy
for this ending as it brings back one of
the most popular characters and actors
from the Sam Raimi trilogy
however originally an alternate ending
was considered that could have brought
Anthony Mackey's new Captain America in
for a post-credits scene or later on in
the movie's third act in an interview
with comic book comm Marvel Studios
creative executive Eric Carroll said
they discussed bringing in Falcons
Captain America at the end once Peter
arced and he's sort of leading the team
and maybe he calls in a favor from Sam
Wilson however this likely didn't happen
because as Kevin Feige has said far from
home is ultimately about Peter getting
out of the shadow
not just of Tony but of the Avengers in
general you're going to step up or not
so although Mackey's Captain America
missed out on debuting and far from home
he'll be taking on caps mantle for the
first time on his new Disney Plus Series
Falcon and the Winter Soldier you can
learn more about why Steve chose Falcon
to be his successor and discover the
future of Captain America in my other
video other characters that could have
appeared in spider-man's second solo
movie at the villains Scorpion and the
vulture actor Michael mandos
introduction to the MCU as Mac Gargan
was teased in homecomings mid-credits
scene where he tried to find out
Spidey's true identity this is not on
you it's on our little spider friend
I've got some boys on the outside who
would love to meet him you know take a
picture slice his throat but his head in
a dryer and I heard a rumor you know who
he is when asked by comic book movie
comm why vulture and scorpion weren't
included in the sequel Jon watt said we
never really found the right moment to
do something like that
but they're both still out there and as
we move forward with these films were
building out this rich world that we can
continually draw from indeed with
spider-man's identity now exposed by
Mysterio's leaked video Mac Gargan
scorpion is bound to take a very keen
interest in Peter Parker and he may try
to get his friends on the outside to
target Peter as he already threatened
before the film came out there was also
talk
Norman Osborn might make an appearance
with rumors suggesting that he or Oscorp
are the new buyers of the Avengers tower
although we do see spidey swing by near
the Avengers Tower any indication of who
may have bought the building has been
cleverly hidden
however when John Watts was asked about
Norman Osborn he explained that Osborn
wasn't considered for this film in the
end but that he is still available for a
future story
Jessica true aka Spider Woman is another
character that Marvel was reportedly
considering to make her MCU debut in far
from home apparently two actresses in
particular was seriously considered for
the role
first was shailene woodley who played
Mary Jane Watson in the amazing
spider-man 2 before her character was
cut from that movie and there was also
Olivia Cooke who you may know from ready
player one sources for the hashtag show
suggested that Jessica drew was going to
be introduced as a Bond girl type
International agent that Peter would
meet on his trip to Europe given
Spidey's incredible popularity it's
surprising that there still hasn't been
a live-action incarnation of a Spider
Woman but hopefully that could change
soon one character that John Watts
confirmed was considered for Spidey
sequel is Captain Britain clearly Peter
Parker's trip to London would have been
a great opportunity for a potential
cameo especially after avengers endgame
we're Peggy Carter's mention of braddock
hints at the existence of Captain
Britain in the MCU however according to
Watts they just couldn't come up with a
clever way of incorporating Captain
Britain into the far from home script
and their attempts to do so ended up
feeling like shoehorned in references a
character that homecoming neatly set up
for future appearances was Miles Morales
when Donald Glover's the Prowler
appeared in Spidey's first solo MCU
movie if you mentioned his nephew miles
however miles didn't appear him far from
home primarily because the character had
just had a high-profile introduction
albeit an animated form in spider-man
into the spider-verse
despite this John Watson said that miles
could still be introduced in a live
action movie further down the line by
the way Tom Holland himself had a
deleted cameo as another Peter Parker in
into the spider-verse a couple more
trailer scenes I spotted which weren't
in the movie include this one of MJ
newly in love couple Betty and net
passing through customs and there's an
extended scene of Peters encounter with
the Italian customs officer which was
trimmed down in the final movie restore
their mic the jammers you know jammers
they're bigger because that's how I'd
like them pajamas okay that's fine and
when hydro-man emerges from the Venice
canals to wreak destruction it looks
like this shot of Peter perched on the
roof of a Venetian bridge was chopped
from the film the shots in the actual
movie has Peter in a different position
and wearing a purple carnival mask so
what do you think of any of these
deleted scenes and you wish any had been
included in the movie share your
thoughts in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to enter the Spider
Man giveaway congratulations to the
winner of my Toy Story 4 giveaway email
me from my about page so I can send you
the prize and if you enjoyed this do hit
that thumbs up button and tap left to
watch another Marvel video or tap write
for some more spider-man or other videos
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time you PK movie
lovers